là je
ple je VO pas pas
pas pas
loinance
av
[Musique]
pas tu regarde
on ref une fois tuas le ver derrière tu
voisas le ver derrière qui va
arriverut prendre
plus plus
[Musique]
dans
ok on y va allez
[Musique]
ok on va se
faire beau ça comment vertical ou est
vertical tu veux qu' un peu plus à
gauche
non c'est
[Musique]
bonter par va Lig
bout Mose sur
ver regarde devant
toi
c'est dans le ver tu vois dans le
[Musique]
ver pas le point
[Applaudissements]
là ok DESC sur un peu sur l' voilà on
est justeessus plus plus vertic plus non
pas plus horizontal
excuse-moi monte monte monte doucement
c'est plus joli
devant c'est pas c'est tu es trop
vertical mon pote là ouais ouais
ok ben reviens ça va pas ok
[Musique]
ouais c'est bien c'est bien ça d'avoir
ça pour
nous avoir des
OK
on le refait tu veux le refaire ou pas
ça